la vez pasada vimos que teníamos dos
tipos de energía cinética traslacional y
rotacional pero estas energías cinéticas
no necesariamente son proporcionales
entre sí en otras palabras la cantidad
de energía cinética traslacional no está
relacionada necesariamente con la
cantidad de energía cinética rotacional
sin embargo tenemos toda una clase de
problemas es decir un tipo especial de
problemas en donde estas fuerzas son
proporcionales y es de lo que vamos a
hablar en este vídeo imaginen que en
lugar de lanzar esta pelota de béisbol
hacemos que ruede en un piso de concreto
así que tomamos esta pelota de béisbol y
la vamos rodando en el concreto y lo que
va a pasar es que va a rotar conforme
avanza hacia adelante y va a ser lo que
llamamos rodar sin resbalar y esto es lo
que probablemente va a hacer esta pelota
de béisbol a menos que empujemos con
mucha fuerza esta pelota o el suelo esté
congelado es como va a rodar de otra
manera esto no se va a resbalar
va a rodar y se va a detener y este
movimiento de rotación se va a dar
conforme avance esta pelota cuando
tenemos una superficie como el cuero
sobre concreto va a tener el agarre
suficiente como para hacer que esto vaya
rodando conforme se va moviendo para
avanzar de manera que las superficies
nunca se van a resbalar entre sí en
otras palabras esta pelota se va a mover
hacia adelante pero no se va a estar
resbalando no va a haber deslizamiento
en esa superficie de aquí lo que
significa que en cualquier momento dado
y esto quizá parezca un poco raro quiere
decir que esta pelota conforme va
rodando en el suelo no tendrá velocidad
en esta parte de abajo la superficie de
aquí abajo no se va a mover al menos con
respecto al suelo ya que de otra manera
se estaría resbalando o deslizando este
punto de la pelota que está en contacto
con el suelo no se está deslizando por
lo que no va a tener velocidad es
extraño esto de veloz
igual a 0 pero aún más extraño es que
cuando vamos manejando en la autopista a
gran velocidad no importa cuánta
velocidad tengamos la parte de abajo de
las llantas tienen una velocidad de 0 no
se están moviendo con respecto al suelo
es el resto de la llanta que está
rotando a lo largo del suelo así que
este punto de abajo como que se queda
pegado por un instante breve de tiempo
de manera que la llanta pueda empujarse
a sí misma hacia adelante y ahora un
nuevo punto se vuelve el punto que tiene
velocidad cero y luego se vuelve a rotar
usando este punto y después un nuevo
punto es el punto que no se mueve y así
sucesivamente otros puntos se están
moviendo este de aquí arriba se mueve
como loco al menos en relación con el
suelo pero el punto que está tocando el
suelo a menos que manejen con poca
precaución y se estén patinando si todo
funciona como debe ser en condiciones
normales de operación la parte de abajo
de la llanta no se debe estar deslizando
en el suelo
significa que ese punto de abajo en la
llanta no tiene velocidad no se mueve
con respecto al suelo lo que quiere
decir que se queda detenido al menos un
instante en este punto no tiene
velocidad y es a lo que nos referimos
con rodar sin resbalar porque esto es
importante esto es importante porque
implica que estas dos energías cinéticas
son proporcionales y aún más implica que
estas dos velocidades la velocidad del
centro de masa y la velocidad angular
también son proporcionales y es lo que
vamos a ver aquí como probamos que la
velocidad del centro de masa es
proporcional a la velocidad angular
imagínense que vamos a cubrir la
superficie de nuestra pelota de béisbol
con pintura estoy a punto de rodar la en
el suelo va a rodar sin resbalar y aquí
le estoy poniendo o la estoy cubriendo
con pintura y voy a rodar esta pelota
hacia adelante que veremos en el suelo
pues veremos que se traza una distancia
que es igual a lo que rodamos la pelota
en otras
habrás si esta pelota de baseball rota
hasta aquí se habrá movido hacia
adelante esta longitud de arco ya que si
esta pelota está rodando sin resbalar
conforme esta pelota esté rotando hacia
adelante se habrá movido hacia adelante
exactamente esta cantidad esta longitud
de arco hacia adelante si viéramos la
huella que deja la pintura de esta
pelota en el suelo tendría una longitud
igual que la longitud de arco que giro
la pelota y por qué nos interesa que
viaje la misma distancia que la longitud
de arco pues porque significa que el
centro de masa de la pelota ha viajado
la longitud de arco hacia adelante el
centro de masa de esta pelota ha viajado
esta distancia hacia adelante y sabemos
que esta distancia que ha recorrido el
centro de masa es igual a la longitud de
arco y que es la longitud de arco
recuerden que tenemos una fórmula para
esto para algo que rota con cierto
ángulo si consideramos el ángulo que va
de aquí a acá nos imaginamos el radio de
esta pelota la longitud de arco
ser igual a r por el cambio en theta que
tanto ángulo ha rotado este objeto pero
noten que esto no se cumple para todos
los puntos de esta pelota por ejemplo
este punto aquí arriba está rotando
alrededor del centro de masa al mismo
tiempo que el centro de masa se está
moviendo hacia adelante por lo que va a
crear una extraña curva en el espacio
que se verá más o menos así y esta
distancia no es necesariamente igual a
la longitud de arco pero el centro de
masa no está rotando alrededor de sí
mismo el centro de masa de esta pelota
está moviéndose en línea recta y es por
eso que podemos decir que el centro de
masa de esta pelota ha viajado una
distancia igual a la cantidad de la
longitud de arco que se movió es igual a
la longitud pintada en el suelo porque
nos interesa esto que la distancia del
centro de masa sea igual a la distancia
de la longitud de arco bien esto
a ambos lados entre el tiempo que le
llevó a hacer este recorrido tendremos
la distancia que recorrió el centro de
masa entre el tiempo pues esto es la
velocidad la velocidad del centro de
masa y esto es igual al radio x delta
theta entre el tiempo y esto es la
rapidez angular por lo que nos muestra
que la velocidad del centro de masa para
algo que está rotando sin resbalar va a
ser igual al radio de ese objeto
multiplicado por su velocidad angular la
velocidad angular alrededor del centro
de masa y esto es importante es algo que
deben recordar ya que cuando un problema
dice que hay algo que está rodando sin
resbalar es básicamente el código para
de igual a r por omega donde b es la
velocidad del centro de masa y omega es
la rapidez angular alrededor del centro
de masa y quizá esto no los impresiones
y me digan que acaso no sabíamos ya que
esto es igual a r por omega si lo
sabíamos pero esto es diferente esta
velocidad que mostramos
aquí es la velocidad del centro de masa
y esta velocidad de acá es la velocidad
de cualquier punto en un objeto que se
encuentra a una distancia r del centro y
está en relación al centro de masa en
otras palabras si aquí tenemos una
pelota que está rotando y si queremos
conocer a una distancia r del centro qué
tan rápido se está moviendo este punto
comparado con la velocidad angular si
esto rota así va a tener cierta rapidez
ve pero es la rapidez ve en relación al
centro de masa y lo que encontramos en
esta ecuación es diferente esta es la
rapidez del centro de masa nos dice qué
tan rápido se está moviendo este centro
de masa y no qué tan rápido se está
moviendo un punto en esta pelota de
béisbol cuando rota en relación al
centro de masa esto nos permite
determinar cuál es la velocidad del
centro de masa lo cual es bastante útil
para muchos problemas y justamente ahora
vamos a resolver algunos ejemplos
vamos a
todo esto y a resolver este ejemplo
digamos que tomamos un cilindro sólido
de 5 kilogramos y que tiene un radio de
2 metros y enrollamos cuerda alrededor
de él luego atamos el extremo suelto al
techo y lo soltamos dejamos que este
cilindro se desenrolla hacia abajo y
conforme rueda va a estar moviéndose
hacia abajo y digamos que lo soltamos a
una altura de 4 metros y queremos saber
cuál es la rapidez del centro de masa
justo antes de que el yoyo toque el
suelo y con yoyo nos referimos a este
cilindro que se está desenredando aunque
realmente no es un yoyo el yoyo tiene
una cavidad adentro en el cual se coloca
la cuerda la cuerda va a estar enrollada
en un pequeño eje en cambio aquí estamos
enrollando nuestra cuerda en el borde
del cilindro lo que es importante ya que
este básicamente es un caso de rodar sin
resbalar y ustedes me pueden decir esto
no está rodando para nada pero sigue
siendo la misma idea
tienen que está cuerda es el suelo y
esto es como una rueda o una bola que
está rodando en el suelo y no estás
resbalando con respecto a este excepto
que en este caso el suelo es la cuerda
este cilindro no se está respaldando con
respecto a la cuerda y esto es algo que
debemos suponer que este cilindro se
está desarrollando pero no se está red
es balance de la cuerda lo que quiere
decir que podemos usar nuestra deducción
anterior la rapidez del centro de masa
de este cilindro va a ser igual al radio
del cilindro multiplicada por la rapidez
angular del cilindro y ya que el centro
de masa se va a estar moviendo hacia
abajo la distancia va a ser igual a la
trazada por la longitud de arco del
borde exterior del cilindro pero no lo
puedo resolver porque no conozco la
velocidad del centro de masa y tampoco
conozco la rapidez angular por lo que
necesito otra idea otra ecuación aquí y
esta idea es la conservación de la
energía este problema pide a gritos se
resuelto con la conservación
energía vamos a hacerlo vamos a poner
todo lo de nuestro sistema y vamos a
decir que la energía se conserva
comienza a una altura de 4 metros lo que
significa que comienza con energía
potencial comienza con mgh y esto en que
se convierte pues este cilindro cuando
llegue al suelo ya no tendrá energía
potencial al menos considerando el punto
más bajo como h igual a cero pero se
estará moviendo así que va a tener
energía cinética va a tener energía
cinética traslacional ya que el centro
de masa de este cilindro se va a estar
moviendo por lo que va a tener una
rapidez y además va a tener energía
cinética rotacional ya que este cilindro
va a estar rotando alrededor del centro
de masa y lo hará al mismo tiempo que se
desplaza hacia abajo el centro de masa
por lo que tenemos que agregar un medio
de iu por omega al cuadrado y sigue
pareciendo que no lo podemos resolver ya
que seguimos sin conocer ver y seguimos
sin conocer omega y es aquí donde es
importante que s
vamos lo que acabamos de ver que nos
llevó algunos minutos de desarrollar
esta es la relación entre la velocidad
del centro de masa y la rapidez angular
por lo que podemos dejar toda esta
fórmula en términos de una de las
variables ya sea sustituyendo b u omega
y vamos a sustituir omega porque
queremos conocer b podemos decir que
omega es igual a la rapidez del centro
de masa entre r así que aquí despejamos
omega y la vamos a sustituir en esta
otra fórmula y nos queda un medio de iu
por la velocidad del centro de masa
entre el radio al cuadrado y ya que
elevamos esto al cuadrado copio y pego
esto y pongo este término al cuadrado la
rapidez del centro de masa al cuadrado
entre el radio al cuadrado y ahora ya se
ve mucho mejor tenemos una sola variable
que es la que queremos encontrar aunque
quizás esta hilos esté desesperando un
poco es el momento de inercia que vamos
a hacer con esto bueno el momento de
inercia
de un cilindro y la mayoría de las veces
ustedes tienen que buscar este dato del
momento de inercia dependiendo del
objeto que estén analizando el momento
de inercia de un cilindro es un medio de
la masa del cilindro multiplicado por el
radio del cilindro al cuadrado así que
tomamos esto y lo sustituimos en y nos
queda copio y pego esto vamos a hacer un
poco de espacio para poder sustituirla y
por el momento de inercia del cilindro
que quedamos es un medio m r al cuadrado
y esto es además de éste un medio que ya
teníamos aquí ahora tenemos otro un
medio del momento de inercia un medio m
por r al cuadrado y resulta que este ere
es la misma que esta otra r tengo r al
cuadrado y uno entre r al cuadrado por
lo que terminan cancelándose y esto es
extraño no importa cuál sea el radio del
cilindro y no sólo eso todos estos
términos tienen la masa en ellos así que
tampoco importa cuál es el tamaño de la
masa del cilindro
va a llegar al suelo con la misma
velocidad en el centro de masa en otras
palabras todos los rollos que tengan la
misma forma van a llegar al mismo tiempo
al suelo siempre y cuando todas las eles
sean iguales y si ignoramos la
resistencia al aire no importa de qué
tamaño sea el yoyo o cuál sea su masa
todos van a llegar al suelo al mismo
tiempo y con la misma rapidez lo que es
bastante extraño y ahora sí ya podemos
resolver esto en el lado izquierdo sólo
nos queda g por h y esto va a ser igual
a un medio la velocidad del centro de
masa al cuadrado más un cuarto de la
velocidad del centro de masa al cuadrado
y esto es igual a tres cuartos la
velocidad del centro de masa si tenemos
un medio y le agregamos un cuarto pues
vamos a tener tres cuartos y si calculo
esto para la velocidad del centro de
masa multiplico gh por cuatro entre tres
en ambos lados hice con la raíz cuadrada
nos va a quedar la raíz cuadrada de 4 g
h entre 3 y ahora sólo tenemos que
sustituir
números aquí esto es igual a esto es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 4 por 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado por 4
metros entre 3 lo que nos dará la
rapidez del centro de masa igual a 7.23
metros por segundo y aquí hay algo que
tenemos que tener en cuenta algunos
problemas pueden lucir diferente de este
pero la forma en que lo resolvemos puede
que sea idéntica por ejemplo podemos
tomar toda esta solución de acá la
copiamos y vamos a ver un nuevo problema
este va a ser sencillo y no nos llevará
mucho tiempo digamos que tomamos el
mismo cilindro lo liberamos de su
posición de reposo en la parte alta de
un plano inclinado que tiene una altura
de 4 metros y dejamos que ruede sin que
resbale en todo este plano inclinado y
nuevamente nos preguntamos cuál va a ser
la rapidez del centro de masa de este
cilindro al llegar hasta abajo
de este plano inclinado pues es el mismo
problema se ve diferente del problema
anterior pero conceptualmente y
matemáticamente es lo mismo esto comenzó
con energía potencial
mgh y termino con energía cinética
traslacional y energía cinética
rotacional ya que la conservación de
energía nos dice que esta energía
potencial se transforma al final en
energía cinética traslacional y energía
cinética rotacional nuevamente si es un
cilindro su momento de inercia va a ser
igual a un medio m por r al cuadrado y
si está rodando sin resbalar nuevamente
podemos reemplazar a omega con b / r ya
que es la misma relación que mantiene
algo que está rodando sin resbalar la
semes también se cancelan y obtenemos el
mismo cálculo la velocidad del centro de
masa de este cilindro al final del plano
inclinado va a ser igual a 7.23 metros
por segundo esta va a ser su rapidez
cuando
rodando desde una altura de 4 metros
en resumen aun cuando la velocidad del
centro de masa de un objeto no es
necesariamente proporcional a la
velocidad angular de ese objeto
alrededor del centro de masa si el
objeto está rotando o rodando sin
resbalar esta relación se va a cumplir
lo que nos permite pasar de ecuaciones
con dos incógnitas a ecuaciones con una
sola incógnita lo que nos va a permitir
despejar la rapidez del centro de masa
del objeto